speaking of schooling did you know joe
biden is going back to his catholic
school days
to try to appeal to religious voters
let's see how successful he'll be i just
walked out the side door of saint
peter's basilica
after a meeting and getting an
opportunity to shake hands and have a
brief conversation with
pope francis the first people i saw were
a group of nuns who
to me epitomize everything pope francis
talked about
in his homily and what he stands for
about generosity to other people about
reaching out
about making it a point to understand
that we are our brother's keeper
and that's what in my experience being
raised as a catholic
and educated by the nuns that's what
those lovely women i'm talking to
symbolize to me so i thought it was a
good omen
when joe biden was vice president his
administration tried to litigate
nuns into the dirt because the nuns
wouldn't provide abortion pills to
people
that's what joe biden did he tried to
force nuns to pay for birth control and
abortion and violate not just
their moral conscience but the faith
that joe biden pretends to hold
basic elements of the faith that the
apostate joe biden pretends to hold
as he supports not just open widespread
abortion
but taxpayer-funded abortion
he signaled that he would do that that
again as president
he's he's overturned his formerly
egregious but somewhat more moderate
stances on abortion now he wants
all taxpayers to pay for it that's why
he was denied the eucharist
because he's in a very clear public
state of grave mortal sin
and shows absolutely no remorse for it
whatsoever the simple fact is
it is not acceptable for any practicing
catholic to vote for joe biden it is not
acceptable and you are imperiling your
soul if you do it
but he's going to try to appeal anyway
still i don't think very many serious
catholics are going to take that
seriously i hope you enjoyed that short
segment from the michael knowles show be
sure to check out the full episode
linked in the description
or download the podcast wherever you
listen to podcasts
[Music]
you